Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode describes acts of violence against men, women and children. It won't be suitable for all listeners. During the 17th century, the Netherlands became one of the world's foremost economic powers thanks to its advances in science, art and commercial trade.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要帮助，请联系当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集描述了针对男性、女性和儿童的暴力行为。它并不适合所有听众。在17世纪，由于科学、艺术和商业贸易的进步，荷兰成为了世界上最重要的经济强国之一。
Then known as the Dutch Republic, its wealth and power flourished through the importing of goods from overseas, with huge ships sent to Asia and Africa to bring back textiles, teas, grains and spices. A popular proverb among the Dutch during this period was, Jesus Christ is good, but trade is better. The Dutch East India Company, known in its homeland as the VOC, was a chartered company established to coordinate trade in India and other countries throughout Southeast Asia. Monopolising all trade to the east, it boasted tens of thousands of employees and its own
当时被称为荷兰共和国，其财富和权力通过从海外进口货物而蓬勃发展，巨大的船只被派往亚洲和非洲带回纺织品、茶叶、谷物和香料。当时荷兰人中流行的一句俗语是：“耶稣基督很好，但贸易更好。”荷兰东印度公司在其国内被称为VOC，是一家旨在协调印度及东南亚其他国家贸易的特许公司。它垄断了所有通往东方的贸易，拥有数万名员工和自己的
private army. Ships operating under its licence were enormous vessels called East India Men, built to carry large amounts of cargo as well as passengers and equipped with cannons and gunners in case pirates launched an attack. Due to their size and weight, these ships moved slowly at an average speed of five knots per hour and typically took eight months to complete a voyage. In 1628, the VOC commissioned the construction of an expensive new flagship to travel to the company's major trade settlement of Batavia, located in what is today the city of Jakarta
私人军队。在其许可下运营的船只是被称为“东印度帆船”的庞大舰艇，专为运载大量货物以及乘客而建造，并配有大炮和炮手以防海盗袭击。由于其体型和重量，这些船只移动缓慢，平均时速为5节，通常需要八个月才能完成一次航行。1628年，东印度公司委托建造一艘昂贵的新旗舰，前往该公司位于巴达维亚的主要贸易定居点，该定居点位于如今的
in Java, Indonesia. And after its destination, the Batavia was a grand vessel that was built in just six months at the exorbitant cost of 100,000 guilders, more than 4.5 million Australian dollars in today's currency. The approximately 55-metre-tall and 56-metre-long ship was made of VOC and featured four decks, three masts and 30 guns, and had the capacity to carry 600 tonnes of supplies. Its upper works were painted pale green with gold and red detailing, and its figurehead, a wooden carving positioned at the bow, was a lion leaping upwards.
印度尼西亚爪哇岛的雅加达市。因其目的地而得名，“巴达维亚”号是一艘宏伟的船只，仅用六个月就建造完成，造价高达10万盾，相当于当今货币的450多万澳大利亚元。这艘高约55米、长约56米的船只由东印度公司建造，拥有四层甲板、三根桅杆和30门大炮，运载补给的能力达到600吨。其上层建筑被漆成淡绿色，带有金色和红色的细节，其船首像——位于船首的木雕——是一只向上跃起的狮子。
In late October 1628, the Batavia set sail from Amsterdam with a fleet of seven other ships carrying 341 people who ranged from VOC officials, sailors and soldiers to relatively well-off passengers travelling with their families. A number of the younger passengers were cabin boys ranging from children to adolescents who were employed on the ship to wait on others. The Batavia was also packed with valuable cargo, including stone to build factories with, silverware, jewels and a fortune in coins that would amount to almost 41 million Australian dollars in today's currency.
在1628年10月下旬，“巴达维亚”号与另外七艘船组成的船队从阿姆斯特丹起航，船上载有341人，其中包括东印度公司官员、水手、士兵以及与家人一起出行的相对富裕的乘客。许多年轻的乘客是船童，年龄从儿童到青少年不等，他们在船上受雇伺候他人。“巴达维亚”号还塞满了宝贵的货物，包括用于建造工厂的石块、银器、珠宝以及一笔巨额硬币，换算成当今的货币价值近41万万澳大利亚元。
Laugh on the ship was harsh, perilous and unpleasant. Sleeping waters were cramped and barrels of drinking water were contaminated with worms and dowry. Outbreaks of infectious and nutritional deficiency diseases were common, resulting in the deaths of 10 passengers. 27-year-old passenger Lucretia Yarns was travelling from her home city of Amsterdam to be reunited with her husband. She was an employee of the VOC and had left to work in the company's Batavia settlement
船上的生活残酷、危险且令人不快。睡眠区拥挤不堪，饮用水桶被蠕虫和泥污污染。传染病和营养缺乏症的爆发很常见，导致10名乘客死亡。27岁的乘客露克丽霞·扬斯（Lucretia Yarns）正从她的家乡阿姆斯特丹出发，准备与丈夫团聚。她是东印度公司的员工，此前曾离开前往该公司在
several years earlier. Shortly after his departure, the couple's three young children all contracted a disease and died. It was unusual for a merchant's wife to follow her husband overseas, but Lucretia was heartbroken and lonely. She was born into wealth and occupied a higher social status, resulting in her travelling on the Batavia with a maid and having her own private cabin. Lucretia, who was regarded as exceptionally beautiful, consistently rebuffed unwanted
几年前设立的巴达维亚定居点工作。在他出发后不久，这对夫妇的三个幼小孩子都感染了疾病并夭折。商人妻子跟随丈夫出海的情况并不常见，但露克丽霞心碎且孤独。她出身富贵，社会地位较高，因此得以带着女佣乘坐“巴达维亚”号，并拥有自己的私人船舱。露克丽霞被认为异常美丽，在漫长的航行中一直断然拒绝
attention from a number of men throughout the long voyage. On the evening of May 14, Lucretia was preparing to retire for the night. As she made her way back to her sleeping quarters, she was confronted by eight men wearing masks. Though she couldn't see their faces, they spoke to one another and she heard their voices. The master salons dragged Lucretia to a quiet corner on the ship's deck where they reached under her skirt to grope her and smeared her face, legs and genitals with tar and animal dung. The assault was over in a matter of seconds.
多名男子不请自来的关注。5月14日晚，露克丽霞正准备休息。当她返回自己的铺位时，遇到了八名戴着面具的男子。虽然她看不到他们的脸，但他们互相交谈，她听到了他们的声音。这群主谋将露克丽霞拖到船甲板的一个安静角落，他们在她的裙子下面伸手猥亵她，并将焦油和动物粪便涂抹在她的脸、腿和生殖器上。袭击在几秒钟内就结束了。
Word of Lucretia Yarn's assault reached the Batavia's commander, upper merchant Francisco who began investigating the matter. Upper merchants were VOC officials who were assigned overall responsibility for a particular fleet. Their task was to ensure the voyage would be profitable for the company's directors. Second in command was the ship's captain, followed by the upper merchant's deputy known as the under merchant. Francisco Pelsart was aged in his early 30s and was a long-time VOC employee, having
关于露克丽霞·扬斯遇袭的消息传到了“巴达维亚”号的指挥官、高级商人弗朗西斯科（Francisco）耳中，他开始调查此事。高级商人是被指派对特定船队负有全面责任的东印度公司官员。他们的任务是确保航行能为公司董事带来利润。第二负责人是船长，其次是高级商人的副手，被称为副商人（under merchant）。弗朗西斯科·佩尔萨特（Francisco Pelsart）三十岁出头，是一名老资历的东印度公司员工，
already completed a seven-year posting in India. Despite his experience, he was indecisive and lacked leadership skills. His command on the Batavia had been difficult at times as he often clashed with the ship's captain, Ariane Jacobs. Just in his mid-40s, Jacobs was a masterful sailor who had completed many voyages, but he was bad tempered, struggled with a drinking problem, and was known to harass female passengers. Pelsart and Jacobs had first met more than a year earlier when both were in India and grew to dislike one another after an altercation that occurred there.
此前已经在印度完成了为期七年的派驻。尽管他经验丰富，但他优柔寡断，缺乏领导能力。他在“巴达维亚”号上的指挥有时很艰难，因为他经常与船长阿里安·雅各布斯（Ariane Jacobs）发生冲突。雅各布斯四十岁出头，是一位经验丰富的航海大师，完成了许多航程，但他脾气暴躁，有酗酒问题，并且有骚扰女性乘客的前科。佩尔萨特和雅各布斯一年多前在印度首次见面，由于当时发生了一场争执，两人逐渐互生厌恶。
During the Batavia's voyage, matters came to a head on April 14, 1629, when the ship stopped near the South African city of Cape Town to restock supplies. By this stage, bad weather had caused the Batavia to separate from all but two other ships in its seven-vessel fleet. While Commander Pelsart was on land bartering for goods, Captain Jacobs, without permission, rowed out in a small boat to visit the accompanying ships. While on board, he got drunk and violent, resulting in a fight. By the time Pelsart returned to the Batavia, official complaints had been lodged against
在“巴达维亚”号的航行期间，矛盾在1629年4月14日达到了顶峰，当时该船停靠在南非城市开普敦附近以补给物资。此时，恶劣的天气导致“巴达维亚”号与七艘船队中除另外两艘船之外的所有船只失散。当佩尔萨特指挥官在岸上易货换取物资时，雅各布斯船长在未获批准的情况下，乘小船划向随行的船只进行探访。在船上，他喝醉并表现出暴力倾向，引发了一场争斗。当佩尔萨特返回“巴达维亚”号时，
his captain. Pelsart reprimanded Jacobs, which led to the humiliated Jacobs deeply resenting his superior. Pelsart continued looking into the group assault against Lucretia Yarns. Though the perpetrators had concealed their faces, Lucretia recognized the voice of one individual and identified him as Yarn Avertz, the ship's bosson, a title given to the senior officer in charge of the Batavia's deck. Pelsart also suspected Captain Jacobs was somehow involved, and was mindful that the captain had attempted to seduce Lucretia on several occasions, but she rejected him.
针对其船长的正式投诉已经提交。佩尔萨特斥责了雅各布斯，这导致受辱的雅各布斯对上级深怀怨恨。佩尔萨特继续调查针对露克丽霞·扬斯的团伙袭击事件。尽管行凶者隐瞒了面容，但露克丽霞认出了其中一个人的声音，并确认他是扬·阿韦茨（Yarn Avertz），该船的船长（bosun，授予负责“巴达维亚”号甲板的高级军官的头衔）。佩尔萨特还怀疑雅各布斯船长也卷入其中，并且注意到船长曾多次试图勾引露克丽霞，但被她拒绝了。
Despite Pelsart's suspicions, he knew arresting both Avertz and Jacobs would displease the crew, so he postponed any further action until they arrived at their destination. When Captain Jacobs had deserted the Batavia at Cape Town to visit its companionships, he was joined by Commander Pelsart's deputy, an undemergent named Euronymous Cornelius. 30-year-old Cornelius was from a well-off, educated family who belonged to the non-conformist Anabaptist Church, a denomination considered controversial in the Dutch Republic. Cornelius followed in his father's footsteps and became an apothecary, preparing and selling medicines through his own shop in the Dutch city of Haarlem.
尽管佩尔萨特心存怀疑，但他知道逮捕阿韦茨和雅各布斯会引起船员不满，因此他推迟了任何进一步的行动，直到他们到达目的地。当雅各布斯船长在开普敦离开“巴达维亚”号去拜访随行船只时，佩尔萨特指挥官的副手、一位名叫埃罗尼穆斯·科尼利厄斯（Euronymous Cornelius）的副商人加入了他的行列。30岁的科尼利厄斯来自一个富裕、受过教育的家庭，信仰不墨守成规的再洗礼派教会，这是一个在荷兰共和国被认为极具争议的教派。科尼利厄斯追随父亲的脚步成为了一名药剂师，在荷兰城市哈勒姆自己的店铺里配制和出售药物。
In November 1627, Cornelius and his wife had a baby boy who was placed in the care of a wet nurse after his mother became ill. Within several weeks, the infant had contracted syphilis from the nurse's breast milk and died. As syphilis is a sexually transmitted disease, this caused a significant scandal. In an effort to save his wife's reputation, Cornelius filed a lawsuit against the wet nurse, though the incident destroyed his career and he found himself unable to pay a number of debts.
1627年11月，科尼利厄斯和他的妻子生下一个男婴，在母亲生病后，婴儿被交由奶妈照料。几周内，婴儿通过奶妈的母乳感染了梅毒并夭折。由于梅毒是通过性传播的疾病，这引发了一场重大丑闻。为了挽救妻子的声誉，科尼利厄斯对奶妈提起诉讼，尽管这起事件毁了他的职业生涯，并且他发现自己无力偿还多笔债务。
Moreover, Cornelius was an associate and disciple of infamous painter Johannes Tarentius, who was convicted on charges of heresy, blasphemy, atheism and Satanism in 1628. Fearful that he would be prosecuted next, Cornelius left his wife and fled to Amsterdam, where he took service with the VOC and was posted to the Batavia. He quickly formed a friendship with Captain Ariane Jacobs, who made his disdain for Commander Francisco Pelsart clear by remarking that, were it not for the presence of other ships in the fleet, quote, I would treat that miserly dog so that he could not come out of his cabin for 14 days and I would quickly make myself master of the ship.
此外，科尼利厄斯是声名狼藉的画家约翰尼斯·塔伦蒂乌斯（Johannes Tarentius）的同伙和信徒，后者于1628年因异端、亵渎神明、无神论和撒旦崇拜罪名被定罪。由于害怕自己成为下一个被起诉的目标，科尼利厄斯抛弃妻子逃往阿姆斯特丹，在那里加入东印度公司并被派往“巴达维亚”号。他很快与阿里安·雅各布斯船长建立了友谊，雅各布斯毫不掩饰对弗朗西斯科·佩尔萨特指挥官的蔑视，评论道：“如果不是因为船队中有其他船只在场，引文，我会把那只吝啬的狗收拾得让他在船舱里呆不上14天，而且我会很快让自己掌控这艘船。”
In response, Cornelius asked Jacobs, and how would you manage that? This did not harbour the same personal resentment against Pelsart, but was eager to take charge of the Batavia and steal the substantial fortune stored on the ship. The pair plotted a mutiny, a form of unlawful rebellion in which the crew of a ship overthrew their leader. Morale amidst the Batavia's crew was low due to the poor conditions and awful treatment they endured, all for a low pay. A few were convinced to join in the mutiny, including Bosun Jarn Avertz, several cadets,
作为回应，科尼利厄斯问雅各布斯：“你将如何做到这一点？”此人对佩尔萨特没有同样的个人怨恨，但渴望掌控“巴达维亚”号并盗取储存在船上的巨额财富。两人密谋哗变，这是一种船员推翻领袖的非法叛乱形式。由于糟糕的条件和恶劣的对待，外加微薄的薪水，“巴达维亚”号船员的士气低落。少数人被说服加入哗变，包括船长扬·阿韦茨、几名学员、
a lance corporal, and some of his soldiers. In order for their plot to work, they needed to isolate the Batavia by steering it away from its remaining fleet. Captain Jacobs achieved this when the ship encountered a storm shortly after sailing away from South Africa's Cape of Good Hope. As it was an uncommon for ships within a fleet to become separated, this did not arouse any suspicion. Despite successfully isolating the Batavia, Cornelius and Jacobs' group of mutineers
一名下士以及他的一些士兵。为了让他们的阴谋得逞，他们需要通过将“巴达维亚”号驶离剩下的船队来使其孤立。当船在驶离南非好望角后不久遭遇风暴时，雅各布斯船长实现了这一点。由于船队中的船只分散并不罕见，这没有引起任何怀疑。尽管成功孤立了“巴达维亚”号，但科尼利厄斯和雅各布斯的哗变团伙
was too small to stage a successful mutiny, so they schemed to turn more men against Commander Pelsart. While disguised, they would attack passenger Lucretia Jarns, whom Pelsart harboured romantic feelings for. In response, Pelsart would then discipline all of the ship's soldiers and sailors, enraging those punished and recruiting them to their cause. However, their plan failed when Pelsart did not take punitive measures against anybody for the assault on Lucretia.
规模太小，无法发动一次成功的哗变，因此他们密谋让更多的人倒戈反对佩尔萨特指挥官。在伪装的情况下，他们将袭击佩尔萨特怀有浪漫情感的乘客露克丽霞·扬斯。作为回应，佩尔萨特随后将惩戒船上的所有士兵和水手，从而激怒那些受罚者并将他们招募到他们的事业中。然而，当佩尔萨特没有对袭击露克丽霞的任何人采取惩罚措施时，他们的计划失败了。
The mutineers speculated that he was just biding his time and intended to take action once their route took them past the Australian mainland, a then uncharted landmass known as Terror Australia Syncognita, the Unknown Southland. They quickly put together a new plan, agreeing that as soon as Pelsart made any arrests for Lucretia's assault, the mutineers would enter his cabin at night and throw him overboard. They would then recruit 120 men to run the ship, throw all remaining passengers into the ocean, and turn to piracy. They planned to sail the Indian Ocean disguised as a VOC ship before retiring in a far-off
哗变者推测他只是在等待时机，打算等航线把他们带过澳大利亚大陆后再采取行动，这是一片当时未绘制地图的陆地，被称为“未知南方大陆”（Terra Australis Incognita）。他们迅速拼凑出一个新计划，一致同意一旦佩尔萨特因露克丽霞遇袭事件进行任何逮捕，哗变者就会在夜间闯入他的船舱并将他扔下海。然后，他们将招募120人来操纵这艘船，把所有剩下的乘客扔进海洋，并转为海盗。他们计划伪装成东印度公司的一艘船在印度洋航行，然后在一个遥远的
land with their stolen loot. Over the next few weeks, the mutineers waited patiently for the signal that it was time to revolve. During this period, ships travelling from Europe to Asia used strong westerly winds in the southern hemisphere named the Roaring Forties to speed east after leaving the Cape of Good Hope. These winds sent them towards the west coast of Australia very quickly, but as there was no accurate way to measure longitude, crews had the gauge when it was time to steer north
地方带着他们的战利品隐退。在接下来的几周里，哗变者耐心等待着起义时机的信号。在此期间，从欧洲开往亚洲的船只利用南半球名为“咆哮西风带”的强劲西风，在离开好望角后向东加速。这些风把他们非常快地送往澳大利亚西海岸，但由于没有准确测量经度的方法，船员们只能通过目测和经验来判断何时该向北转向。
from sight and experience alone. If they made a mistake and kept sailing east, they ran the risk of hitting the Australian mainland. June 1629 marked the Batavia's eighth month at sea. By the early morning of June 4, it had been three weeks since Lucretia Yarns had been assaulted by the mutineers, and the Batavia was making use of the Roaring Forties. It was a clear night, and the moon provided ample light to Seabye. Shortly after 3am, Commander Pelsart was violently thrown from his bed following a rough, terrible
如果他们犯了错并继续向东航行，他们就会冒撞上澳大利亚大陆的风险。1629年6月标志着“巴达维亚”号在海上的第八个月。到6月4日清晨，距离露克丽霞·扬斯被哗变者袭击已经过去了三周，“巴达维亚”号正在利用“咆哮西风带”。那是一个晴朗的夜晚，月光为航行提供了充足的光线。凌晨3点刚过，佩尔萨特指挥官在一阵剧烈、可怕的晃动后被从床上重重地甩了下来。
movement. He ran out to the deck, and upon seeing that the ship had run directly into an enormous coral reef, he shouted at Captain Yakub's, What have you done, that through your reckless carelessness, you have run this noose around our necks? Yakub's claim to the accident was not his fault, stating that he had sighted surfspray breaking against the reef from a distance, but the ship's lookout insisted it was nothing more than the moon's reflection on the water.
他跑到甲板上，看到船直接撞上了一座巨大的珊瑚礁，便对雅各布斯船长吼道：“你做了什么，竟因你的鲁莽大意，把这个绞索套在了我们的脖子上？”雅各布斯声称事故不是他的错，并辩称他从远处看到了拍打着礁石的白色浪花，但船上的瞭望员坚称这不过是月光在水面上的反射。
As it was unclear whether the tide was high or low, the crew wondered whether they might have simply run aground in shallows and would be able to float back out to sea once the water level rose. But after waiting several hours, it became clear that the collision had taken place at high tide. Falling water levels revealed they were surrounded by rocks, reefs and small islands. The impact had careened the ship half out of the ocean, with sharp coral tearing away its rudder and gouging its timber sides.
由于不清楚当时是涨潮还是落潮，船员们想知道他们可能只是在浅滩上搁浅，一旦水位上升就能漂回大海。但在等待了几个小时后，人们发现碰撞发生在涨潮时分，这一点变得很清楚。下降的水位显示他们周围环绕着岩石、礁石和小岛。撞击使船有一半冲出了海洋，锋利的珊瑚撕裂了船舵，并在其木制船体上凿出了大洞。
Several frightened individuals jumped overboard and either drowned or were pierced by the sharp coral below. The crew began discarding cannons and gunners to lighten the Batavia's load, and just after dawn they cut its main mast down as well. Historians were later determined that the Batavia struck a shoal called Morning Reef in the northern most cluster of the Abrolis, a network of 122 barren, windswept islands and associated coral reefs in the Indian Ocean. They are located roughly 60km west of what is today the city of Geraldton in Western Australia.
几个惊恐的人跳进海里，要么淹死了，要么被底部的尖锐珊瑚刺穿。船员们开始丢弃大炮和炮手以减轻“巴达维亚”号的载重，黎明刚过，他们也砍倒了主桅杆。历史学家后来确定，“巴达维亚”号撞上了阿博洛霍斯群岛最北端的一处名为“早晨礁”的浅滩，这是一个由122个贫瘠、风吹日晒的岛屿以及印度洋相关珊瑚礁组成的群岛网络。它们位于现今西澳大利亚州杰拉尔顿市以西约60公里处。
There are three distinct groups of islands, all of which have little in the way of vegetation or wildlife, aside from a few sea lions and birds. Seven hours after the collision, as preparations were underway to safely relocate Batavia's passengers, the ship burst open below the waterline and its hull began filling with water. The ship's crew began rowing the passengers away in the Batavia's longboat, an open vessel capable of holding 40 people and its yaw, a sailboat that could carry 23. They were set down on an island about 2km from the shipwreck. It was a tiny, hard and flat land mass with no vegetation, sand or shelter.
这里有三个截然不同的岛屿群，除了少量的海狮和鸟类外，所有岛屿几乎都没有植被或野生动物。碰撞发生七小时后，正当人们准备安全转移“巴达维亚”号的乘客时，船在水线下方爆裂，船体开始进水。船员们开始用“巴达维亚”号的长艇（一种可容纳40人的开放式船只）和 Yaw（一艘可载23人的帆船）将乘客划走。他们被安置在距离沉船约2公里处的一个岛屿上。这是一块极小、坚硬且平坦的陆地，没有植被、沙子或庇护所。
Broken and sharp coral pieces lay all over the ground, making it difficult to walk on. By dusk, a number of people had been transferred to the island, including all of the women and children. 150 pints of drinking water, barrels of wine, meat and bread, and a casket full of valuable trade goods such as jewellery, gold and precious stones were also transported to land. Rescue work paused at night when it became too dark to see. Only 120 people still remained on the slowly crumbling Batavia. At dawn the following morning, efforts to retrieve those still stranded on the Batavia
破碎而锋利的珊瑚碎片铺满地面，使人寸步难行。到了黄昏，许多人已被转移到岛上，包括所有的妇女和儿童。150品脱的饮用水、一桶桶的葡萄酒、肉和面包，以及装满珠宝、黄金和宝石等珍贵贸易品的小箱子也被运送到陆地上。夜幕降临、能见度变差时，救援工作暂停。只有120人仍然留在缓缓解体的“巴达维亚”号上。第二天黎明，检索仍滞留在“巴达维亚”号上人员的工作
recommenced. The small island closest to the ship became overcrowded, so 180 men, women and children were moved to a larger land mass, roughly 800 metres away, that had a sandy beach. They were given a limited supply of food, while Commander Pelsart, Captain Jacobs, all of the senior VOC company officials, a number of sailors, two women and one infant, remained on the smaller island with the longboat and yaw. Commander Pelsart was convinced to travel to the Australian mainland to find supplies. As the journey would require a couple of days' preparation, he opted to explore other nearby
重新开始。离船最近的小岛变得拥挤不堪，因此180名男人、女人和儿童被转移到大约800米外、拥有沙滩的较大陆地上。他们获得了有限的食物供应，而佩尔萨特指挥官、雅各布斯船长、所有东印度公司的高级官员、多名水手、两名妇女和一个婴儿，则与长艇和小帆船一起留在了较小的岛上。佩尔萨特指挥官被说服前往澳大利亚大陆寻找补给。由于这段旅程需要几天的准备时间，他选择在此期间探索附近的其他
islands in the meantime. Before departing on their expedition, Pelsart and some of his companions rode over to the larger island where the majority of survivors were now stationed to give them a barrel of drinking water and explain their plans. As they approached, the survivors gathered together on the shoreline. Fearful that they would be mocked and prevented from leaving, the men rowing refused to stop and wouldn't allow Pelsart to deliver the water. Pelsart continued north to inspect the two largest islands in their vicinity, where he
岛屿。在出发进行远征之前，佩尔萨特和一些同伴骑马前往幸存者现在驻扎的较大岛屿，给他们带去了一桶饮用水并解释了他们的计划。当他们靠近时，幸存者们聚集在海岸线上。由于害怕遭到嘲笑并不准离开，划船的男人们拒绝停船，也不允许佩尔萨特递送水。佩尔萨特继续向北检查他们附近最大的两个岛屿，在那里
dug for water but found none. He returned to his camp on the small inlet nearest the Batavia and on June 8, four days after the shipwreck, departed for the Australian mainland. He left behind a note explaining his actions and ordered his crewmen to sign an oath confirming that their mission was to search for water. They set sail in Batavia's longboat with the smaller yaw tied to the back. The longboat was designed to carry 40 people but as no one from Pelsart's island wanted to be left behind, it held 48 in total.
他挖掘水源却一无所获。他返回了位于离“巴达维亚”号最近的小海湾的营地，并在6月4日海难发生的四天后出发前往澳大利亚大陆。他留下了一张纸条解释自己的行为，并命令船员签署誓言，确认他们的任务是寻找水源。他们乘坐“巴达维亚”号的长艇起航，较小的 yaw 绑在后面。长艇原本设计可搭载40人，但由于佩尔萨特岛上没有人愿意被留下，总共挤了48人。
They left all the ships recovered jewels and coins behind. The group sailed north along the western Australian coast. The barren land was framed by jagged cliffs that soared up to 228 metres high. On several occasions, they managed to row to a shoreline and succeeded in collecting rainwater but never found a permanent freshwater supply. After sailing for a week without success, it was decided that they should continue on to their original destination of Batavia in Indonesia to seek rescue assistance from the VOC.
他们把船上打捞上来的珠宝和硬币都留在了原地。这群人沿着西澳大利亚海岸向北航行。贫瘠的陆地被高达228米的锯齿状悬崖所环绕。在好几次机会中，他们设法划船靠岸并成功收集了雨水，但从未找到永久的淡水供应。在毫无收获地航行了一周后，人们决定继续前往他们最初的目的地印尼巴达维亚，向东印度公司寻求救援协助。
Upon learning of Commander Pelsart's departure, the near-200 survivors on the Big Island were left devastated. They accused their leader of abandoning them and dubbed the small inlet where Pelsart had camped, Trader's Island. Their own island, which measured 270 metres wide and half a kilometre long, was named Batavia's Graveyard. Then Mike Dash described it as a strip of coral rubble, where the only living thing was the wind.
得知佩尔萨特指挥官离开后，大岛上近200名幸存者感到大受打击。他们指责领袖抛弃了他们，并将佩尔萨特曾扎营的小海湾称为“商人岛”。他们自己的岛屿长半公里、宽270米，被命名为“巴达维亚的墓地”。麦克·达什（Mike Dash）将其描述为“一条珊瑚碎石带，唯一的生物只有风”。
The shipwreck survivors landed there at the beginning of the Southern Hemisphere's winter, which regularly battered the area with storms and fierce gales. Of those stranded on Batavia's graveyard, at least 100 were VOC soldiers or sailors, while more than a dozen others were men with trade experience such as carpenters and blacksmiths. There were 21 women, the majority of whom were wives of the crew, a number of teenagers and children, and two infants who were born during the voyage. Most of the population's food and water supplies were depleted within a day, and anxieties only increased when Commander Pelsart sailed away with the other VOC officials.
海难幸存者在南半球冬季开始时登陆该地，该地区经常受到风暴和狂风的袭击。在滞留在“巴达维亚墓地”的人中，至少有100名东印度公司的士兵或水手，另外还有十多名具有木匠和铁匠等贸易经验的人。这里有21名妇女，其中大多数是船员的妻子，一些青少年和儿童，以及两个在航行期间出生的婴儿。该地大部分的人口食物和水供应在一天内就耗尽了，而当佩尔萨特指挥官与其他东印度公司官员扬帆远去时，焦虑感只增不减。
Some survivors were driven to drinking seawater or their own urine, while 10 people died from dehydration. It finally rained on the sixth and seventh days of their ordeal, allowing them to collect a valuable drinking water. Meanwhile, 70 men had chosen to stay on the Batavia, including mutineer Euronymous Cornelius. They pillaged supplies and helped themselves to food and alcohol. When the ship started flooding and breaking apart, it became harder and harder for them to find safe, dry places.
一些幸存者被迫饮用海水或自己的尿液，同时有10人死于脱水。在他们苦难的第六天和第七天，终于下雨了，这让他们得以收集宝贵的饮用水。与此同时，有70名男子选择留在“巴达维亚”号上，其中包括哗变者埃罗尼穆斯·科尼利厄斯。他们掠夺物资，自行享用食物和酒精。当船开始进水并解体时，他们越来越难以找到安全、干燥的地方。
Some jumped overboard, attempting to whether float or swim to safety. Most failed, with 40 people drowning as a result. On June 12, one week after the collision, the ship collapsed completely. Just as a toll started disintegrating, Cornelius jumped from the deck and grasped onto a pole from a mast that had already landed in the ocean. Clutching it, he floated towards the shallows, spending two days in the water before reaching Batavia's graveyard. By this time, the survivors had created a functioning camp on the northeast portion of the island.
有些人跳船，试图漂浮或游向安全地带。大多数人失败了，导致40人溺水身亡。6月12日，即碰撞发生一周后，船彻底坍塌了。就在船体开始解体时，科尼利厄斯从甲板跳下，抓住了已经落入海中的一根桅杆杆子。紧紧抓住它，他漂向浅滩，在水中度过了两天，然后才到达“巴达维亚的墓地”。此时，幸存者们已经在岛屿的东北部建立了一个正常运转的营地。
As the ship collapsed, more supplies and useful wreckage kept washing up. Tents were crafted from canvas and mast poles, driftwood was used for fires, and barrels of wine, water and vinegar had also been recovered. The survivors hunted sea lions and birds for food, decimating the wildlife population within a week. Cornelius was taken to a dry area, given a meal and a change of clothes, as well as a bed to sleep in. Prior to his arrival, a small council had been established, tasked with governing the
随着船体的坍塌，更多的物资和有用的残骸不断被冲上岸。帐篷是用帆布和桅杆搭建的，浮木用来生火，葡萄酒、水和醋的木桶也被打捞上来。幸存者们捕猎海狮和鸟类作为食物，在一周内就使当地的野生动物数量锐减。科尼利厄斯被带到干燥地区，吃了一顿饭，换了干衣服，并分到了一张床睡觉。在他到达之前，一个小委员会已经成立，负责管理
island's population. The role of council leader was initially given to the only survivor with any semblance of rank, a surgeon who was popular with the ship's crew, but lacked experience in command. As commander Pelsart's deputy, Cornelius had a rank and status that no one else present could claim, and he was immediately elected to lead the council. Cornelius enjoyed the authority he was granted, but was concerned that the large number of survivors would drain the island's resources and become a threat to his own survival. His worries increased when one of the young men who had been recruited for the intended
岛上的人口。委员会领导的角色最初交给了唯一带有某种军阶的幸存者——一位深受船员欢迎但缺乏指挥经验的外科医生。作为佩尔萨特指挥官的副手，科尼利厄斯拥有在场其他人无法比拟的军阶和地位，他随即被推选领导委员会。科尼利厄斯享受着被授予的权威，但担心大量的幸存者会耗尽岛上的资源，成为他自身生存的威胁。当其中一名曾被招募参与“巴达维亚”号预谋
mutiny on the Batavia started revealing details of the plot to others because he was angry Captain Jacobs left him behind. He didn't share that Cornelius had also been involved, but Cornelius was unnerved nonetheless. If word spread that he had been part of a scheme to seize control of a VOC ship, there was a chance he would be arrested and tried for treason when help arrived. As such, Cornelius began plotting another mutiny. He believed that if he had a group of loyal supporters, he would be able to overpower any rescuers and commandeer their vessel to assume a life of piracy.
哗变的年轻男子因为对雅各布斯船长将他留下感到愤怒，开始向其他人透露该阴谋的细节时，他的担忧增加了。他没有说科尼利厄斯也参与其中，但科尼利厄斯依然感到不安。如果他曾参与夺取东印度公司船只计划的消息传开，救援到来时他将面临被捕和叛国罪审判的风险。因此，科尼利厄斯开始策划另一次哗变。他相信，如果拥有一群忠诚的支持者，他就能够制服任何救援人员并强占他们的船只，从而开始海盗生涯。
He was known to be a charismatic and well-spoken individual, and by late June he had successfully recruited two dozen men, including some of the original mutiners as well as army cadets. He then stockpiled all of the swords, daggers and muskets that had been saved from the ship, keeping them in a single storage area that he controlled. He sent some of his men out on scouting missions to other islands to determine whether survival elsewhere would be possible. Using boats crafted from the ship's wreckage, the men inspected several islands, including the two large ones Commander Pelsart had already visited, which were given the collective name
他以具有个人魅力和口才流利而闻名，到6月下旬，他已成功招募了二十多名男子，其中包括最初的哗变者以及陆军学员。随后，他将从船上抢救出来的所有剑、匕首和火枪集中起来，保存在他控制的一个单一储藏区内。他派他的一些人去其他岛屿进行侦察任务，以确定在别处生存是否可行。利用由船体残骸制作的船只，这些人检查了几个岛屿，包括佩尔萨特指挥官已经访问过的那两个大岛，由于其中较小的岛屿上有一座小山，它们被统称为
of the Highland due to a hill that rose from the smaller of the two. They found no drinking water and little in the way of food. Despite this, Cornelius proclaimed that his men had discovered decent resources elsewhere and announced that some people would be moved to other islands so that Batavia's graveyard wouldn't be overwhelmed. He promised that their supplies would be replenished as needed. 40 men, women and children were transported to an island to the west, dubbed Seals Island. Fifteen others were sent to the small inlet that once harboured Commander Pelsart and
“高地”。他们没有找到饮用水，食物也很少。尽管如此，科尼利厄斯宣称他的手下在别处发现了体面的资源，并宣布将把一些人转移到其他岛屿，以免“巴达维亚的墓地”人满为患。他承诺会根据需要为他们补充物资。40名男人、女人和儿童被运送到西部的一个岛屿，被称为“海豹岛”。另有15人被送往曾经庇护过佩尔萨特指挥官和
the other VOC officials, Traders Island. Then, Cornelius announced that a third group comprised of 20 soldiers would also be sent away to source drinking water from the Highland. He told the soldiers to send smoke signals once they found water and someone would come to collect them. In actual fact, his plan was to remove the most threatening soldiers who were loyal to the VOC by marooning them on the islands that were furthest away. By dispatching these three groups, Cornelius successfully cut the population of Batavia's
其他东印度公司官员的小海湾“商人岛”。接着，科尼利厄斯宣布，由20名士兵组成的第三组也将被送往高地寻找饮用水。他告诉士兵们一旦找到水就发出烟雾信号，会有人来接他们。实际上，他的计划是通过将最忠于东印度公司、最具威胁性的士兵流放到最远的岛屿来铲除他们。通过派遣这三组人，科尼利厄斯成功地削减了“巴达维亚”
graveyard by a third and removed nearly four dozen strong, able-bodied men from his island. Cornelius' next plan was to overhaul the council, as other members could vote against any of his decisions that they didn't agree with. An opportunity arose on July 4, exactly one month after the Batavia struck the reef. Cornelius was informed that a soldier had been stealing wine from a storage tent and sharing it with a friend. Although the involvement of the second accused was difficult to prove, Cornelius sentenced the both men to die, knowing his fellow counsellors would object.
墓地三分之一的人口，并从他的岛上移走了近四打强壮、能干的男子。科尼利厄斯的下一步计划是改组委员会，因为其他成员可能会对他的任何不同意决定投反对票。机会出现在7月4日，即“巴达维亚”号触礁整整一个月后。科尼利厄斯接到通知称，一名士兵从储藏帐篷里偷了酒并与朋友分享。尽管第二名被指控者的涉案情况很难证明，但科尼利厄斯判处两名男子死刑，明知他的同僚委员们会对此反对。
In response to their outcry, he dissolved the council, gaining absolute power over the 130-plus people on Batavia's graveyard. The next day, Cornelius replaced the ousted council members with three of his most loyal followers. Their first act was to carry out the execution of the two wine thieves. The soldier was killed, but his friend's fate is unknown, with some speculating that he escaped to another island. That same day, Cornelius accused two carpenters of planning to sail away on a makeshift raft.
面对他们的强烈抗议，他解散了委员会，获得了对“巴达维亚墓地”130多人的绝对权力。第二天，科尼利厄斯用他最忠实的三个追随者取代了被赶下台的委员会成员。他们的第一项行动就是对两名偷酒贼执行死刑。这名士兵被杀了，但他的朋友的命运尚不清楚，有人猜测他逃到了另一个岛上。同一天，科尼利厄斯指控两名木匠密谋乘坐临时木筏逃跑。
Within hours, both men were executed by two of Cornelius' mutineers. One later boasted that his sword went through his victim, quote, as easily as butter. Cornelius ordered the killings under the guise of law enforcement, as he was vastly outnumbered by the island's population and couldn't risk an uprising. Days passed, and the soldiers sent to the Highland in search of resources had yet to release any smoke signals. Cornelius declared that several parties of three to four individuals would be dispatched to assist them.
几个小时内，两名男子就被科尼利厄斯的两个哗变者处决了。其中一人后来吹嘘说，他的剑刺穿受害者时“就像切黄油一样容易”。科尼利厄斯以执法为幌子下达了杀戮命令，因为岛上的人口数量远多于他们，他冒不起引发起义的风险。数日过去，被派往高地寻找资源的士兵尚未发出任何烟雾信号。科尼利厄斯宣布将分派几支由三到四人组成的小分队前去协助他们。
The first group, consisting of two soldiers and two sailors, were escorted to the Highland via boat by David Zavank, a member of Cornelius' hand-picked council. As soon as they were out of sight, Zavank and his crew of six mutineers launched an attack. They bound three of their passengers by the wrists and ankles, then threw them overboard. The remaining passenger was given mercy on the condition he swear allegiance to Cornelius. Two days later, the same trap was used again to drown two more men. Hans Hardens had been travelling on the Batavia with his wife Anakin and their six-year-old daughter Hylatrin.
第一组由两名士兵和两名水手组成，由科尼利厄斯亲自挑选的委员会成员大卫·扎万克（David Zavank）护送乘船前往高地。一旦他们离开视线，扎万克和他的六名哗变者船员便发起了袭击。他们绑住其中三名乘客的手腕和脚踝，然后将他们扔进海里。剩下的那名乘客在宣誓效忠科尼利厄斯的条件下被饶了一命。两天后，同样的陷阱再次被用来淹死另外两个人。汉斯·哈登斯（Hans Hardens）曾与妻子阿纳金（Anakin）以及他们六岁的女儿海拉特林（Hylatrin）一同乘坐“巴达维亚”号。
He had submitted to Cornelius, likely to ensure provisions for his family. Uncertain as to whether he could trust Hans, Cornelius carried out a test of his loyalty. On July 8, he invited Hans and his wife to join him for a meal in his private tent. Meanwhile, a mutineer crept into the Hardens' family tent and strangled six-year-old Hylatrin to death. She was one of nine people who had been murdered under Cornelius' rule so far. And afterwards, Hans Hardens signed a loyalty oath to the mutineers. Private Webby Hayes was leading the soldiers searching for resources on the Highland.
他曾向科尼利厄斯屈服，可能是为了确保家人的口粮。由于不确定是否能信任汉斯，科尼利厄斯对他的忠诚度进行了一次测试。7月8日，他邀请汉斯和他的妻子一起在他的私人帐篷里用餐。与此同时，一名哗变者潜入哈登斯一家的帐篷，将六岁的海拉特林勒死。她是在科尼利厄斯统治下迄今被谋杀的九人之一。随后，汉斯·哈登斯签署了效忠哗变者的誓言。列兵韦比·海耶斯（Webby Hayes）正带领士兵在高地寻找资源。
Little is known of his background, but he was a skilled fighter and a natural leader. The group found nothing substantial on the smaller of the two islands. After several days, they explored the second larger island. It was separated from the first by a one-and-a-half-kilometre sandbank that appeared at low tide. This island was far more abundant in wildlife than any of the others the survivors had encountered. It was populated by wallabies, snakes and birds, and there were numerous fishing spots. But they struggled to find a freshwater supply. Subsisting on rainwater, bird's eggs, wallabies and fish, they explored the area more thoroughly
人们对他的背景知之甚少，但他是一名出色的战士和天生的领袖。这群人在较小的两个岛屿上没有发现任何实质性的东西。几天后，他们探索了第二个较大的岛屿。它与第一个岛屿被一条在退潮时出现的1.5公里长的沙洲隔开。这个岛屿的野生动物比幸存者遇到的任何其他岛屿都要丰富得多。这里生活着沙袋鼠、蛇和鸟类，并且有许多钓鱼点。但他们很难找到水源。他们靠雨水、鸟蛋、沙袋鼠和鱼维生，比以往的任何小组都更彻底地探索了该地区。
than any of the earlier groups had done. On July 9, they discovered two natural wells hidden beneath slabs of limestone, a sedimentary rock that typically forms in shallow marine waters. One of the wells was three metres deep and full of freshwater. They hastily lit three fires to alert the survivors to the south of their crucial discovery. The 15 people stationed on Traders Island noticed the smoke signals right away. They quickly boarded their two makeshift boats and began rowing towards the Highland. On Batavia's graveyard, Cornelius initially ignored the smoke signals, until he noticed
7月9日，他们在通常在浅海中形成的沉积岩——石灰岩板块下发现了两个隐藏的天然井。其中一口井深三米，满是淡水。他们匆忙点燃三处篝火，以提醒南部的幸存者他们这一关键发现。驻扎在商人岛上的15人立刻注意到了烟雾信号。他们迅速登上两艘临时制作的船只，开始向高地划去。在“巴达维亚的墓地”，科尼利厄斯最初无视这些烟雾信号，直到他注意到
the two Traders Island boats heading in their direction. He ordered his men to attack, and two of his most trusted followers, David Zavunk and Conrad Van Hyssen, jumped into a boat with five other mutineers to pursue them. They caught up to the Traders Island survivors and ordered them to stop before boarding their vessels. The passengers, consisting mostly of soldiers and sailors, but also three women and two children, were forced to surrender. Several jumped into the ocean to escape, only to drown.
两艘商人岛的船只正朝他们的方向驶来。他命令手下发起进攻，他最信任的两名追随者大卫·扎温克（David Zavunk）和康拉德·范·海森（Conrad Van Hyssen）与另外五名哗变者跳上一艘船去追赶他们。他们追上了商人岛的幸存者，并命令他们停船然后登上了他们的船只。船上的乘客主要由士兵和水手组成，但也有三名妇女和两名儿童，他们被迫投降。几个人跳进海洋企图逃跑，结果却淹死了。
The rest were taken back to Batavia's graveyard. David Zavunk raced over to consult with Cornelius. He then ran back towards the shallows where the captives were being held, crying out, kill. Cornelius' men stabbed both children and all of the men, before rowing the three women out to sea and throwing them overboard. The massacre took place in full view of witnesses, making it the first time that many of the survivors realized the true nature of the man who was leading them.
其余人被带回“巴达维亚的墓地”。大卫·扎温克赶去与科尼利厄斯商议。接着，他跑回关押俘虏的浅滩，大喊着：“杀。”科尼利厄斯的部下刺死了所有的儿童和所有男子，然后把这三名妇女划到海里并将她们扔下海。这场大屠杀是在目击者众目睽睽之下发生的，这是许多幸存者第一次意识到统治他们的这个男人的真实本性。
In the days following the slaughter of the residents of Traders Island, roughly a dozen more men declared their loyalty to Cornelius. The most violent mutineers, emboldened after committing a public massacre, regularly tormented others by taking their belongings and threatening them. The bloodshed continued, and people lived in fear of inadvertently drawing attention to themselves. Eleven survivors were suffering from illnesses such as scurvy or fever, and had been isolated to a communal tent.
在屠杀商人岛居民后的几天里，大约十几名男子向科尼利厄斯宣誓效忠。最暴力的哗变者在公开大屠杀后气焰嚣张，经常通过抢夺他人财物和威胁他人来折磨别人。流血事件仍在继续，人们生活在无意中引起注意的恐惧中。11名幸存者患上了坏血病或发烧等疾病，并被隔离在一个公共帐篷里。
Cornelius felt those in poor health were draining the island's resources. On July 10, a mutineer, following his orders, entered the quarantine tent late at night and slit the throats of everyone inside. From that point on, it became extremely dangerous for anyone other than the mutineers to fall sick. Over time, more and more ill people were murdered, commonly at night when they were at them as vulnerable. By July 14, less than two weeks after the murders started, the mutineers had killed
科尼利厄斯觉得那些健康状况不佳的人正在耗尽岛上的资源。7月10日，一名哗变者遵照他的命令，在深夜潜入隔离帐篷，割断了里面所有人的喉咙。从那时起，除了哗变者之外，任何人生病都变得极其危险。随着时间的推移，越来越多的病人被谋杀，通常是在他们最脆弱的夜晚。到7月14日，即谋杀开始不到两周后，哗变者已经杀害了
nearly 50 survivors, lowering the population of Batavia's graveyard to around 90. Those residing on the Highland and Seales Island lived in relative safety out of reach, though it wasn't long before Cornelius turned his attention to them. On July 15, Cornelius ordered seven mutineers to kill all the male inhabitants of Seales Island. As well as being armed with swords and daggers, the mutineers had crafted weapons called Morning Stars which typically consisted of a spiked ball at the end of a chain attached to a piece of wood.
近50名幸存者，使“巴达维亚的墓地”的人口减少到约90人。居住在高地和海豹岛的人在够不着的地方过着相对安全的生活，不过没过多久，科尼利厄斯就把注意力转向了他们。7月15日，科尼利厄斯命令七名哗变者杀死海豹岛上的所有男性居民。哗变者除了配备剑和匕首外，还制作了被称为“晨星锤”的武器，通常由连接在木头上的一条链子末端的带刺铁球组成。
The mutineers' version consisted of half-bent strips of lead with long nails attached. The rope was tied to one end so they could be swung at victims' heads. Leading the attack were Cornelius' chief executioners, David Zavunk and Cornrat Van Heissen. As soon as they landed on Seales Island, four men and six boys were stabbed and killed. Those who were wounded were dragged to the shore to be drowned. Fifteen cabin boys managed to outrun the mutineers and hide. The four female inhabitants, as per Cornelius' instruction, were spared.
叛变者的武器是用半弯的铅条绑上长钉制成的。绳子系在一端，这样他们就可以把它们挥向受害者的头部。领导这次袭击的是科尼利乌斯的首席刽子手大卫·扎温克（David Zavunk）和康拉特·范·海森（Cornrat Van Heissen）。他们一登陆西尔斯岛（Seales Island），就有四名男子和六名男孩被刺身亡。受伤的人被拖到岸边淹死。十五名船舱男孩设法跑过叛变者并藏了起来。根据科尼利乌斯的指示，四名女性居民被饶了一命。
Eight men escaped to the Highland using boats they had crafted in a secluded area of the island. After slaughtering half of Seales Island's population, the mutineers returned to Batavia's graveyard. Three days later, on July 18, Cornelius ordered his men to return to Seales Island after dark and finish the job. Upon arrival, Zavunk handed a mutineer his knife and instructed him to kill the four women.
八名男子利用他们在岛上偏僻地区制作的船只逃到了高地。在屠杀了一半的西尔斯岛人口后，叛变者回到了巴达维亚墓地。三天后的7月18日，科尼利乌斯命令他的手下在天黑后返回西尔斯岛完成任务。到达后，扎温克把他的刀递给了一个叛变者，并指示他杀死这四个女人。
Without hesitation, the mutineer went to a heavily pregnant woman named Mike and Source, took her by the hand and said, Mike and Love, you must die before throwing her down and cutting her throat. The other three women were also murdered. Twelve of the cabin boys were stabbed and bludgeoned. Those who didn't die immediately were drowned at sea. Three boys survived by running away and hiding in bushes. They were safe until almost a week later, on July 24, when they emerged in sight of
叛变者毫不犹豫地走到一个名叫迈克和索源（Mike and Source）的怀孕晚期的妇女身边，拉着她的手说“迈克和爱，你必须死”，然后把她摔倒在地并割断了她的喉咙。其他三个女人也被谋杀。十二名船舱男孩被刺伤和殴打。那些没有立即死去的人在海里淹死了。三个男孩通过逃跑并藏在灌木丛中幸存下来。他们一直很安全，直到近一周后的7月24日，当他们出现在……
Batavia's graveyard. Cornelius saw them and sent men to capture them. They were forced onto a boat with one of the boys made to throw the other two overboard to drown. He was permitted to live in exchange for becoming a mutineer. Towards the end of July, Cornelius ordered increasingly violent and shocking deaths. In one instance, he became enraged by a sick baby girl who cried constantly at night. As a former pharmacist, he offered the child's mother a medicine he'd mixed, claiming it
巴达维亚墓地的视线中。科尼利乌斯看到了他们，并派人去抓捕他们。他们被迫上了一艘船，其中一个男孩被迫将另外两个男孩扔进海里淹死。作为成为叛变者的交换，他被允许活下来。七月底，科尼利乌斯下令进行越来越暴力和令人震惊的杀戮。有一次，他被一个晚上不停哭泣的生病女婴惹恼了。作为前药剂师，他给孩子的母亲提供了一种他调配的药物，声称它……
would help. This would be the only time he attempted to kill someone by his own hands. After consuming the concoction, the baby entered a comatose state but didn't die. The following night, Cornelius had a mutineer strangle her. Cornelius' egomania went unchecked. He wore Commander Francisco Pelsar's expensive clothes and would change outfits multiple times a day. His most trusted followers were also given special outfits made from expensive high-quality
会有所帮助。这将是他唯一一次试图亲手杀死某人。喝下这种混合物后，婴儿进入了昏迷状态，但并没有死。第二天晚上，科尼利乌斯让一个叛变者勒死了她。科尼利乌斯的自大狂变得无法无天。他穿着指挥官弗朗西斯科·佩尔萨特（Francisco Pelsar）昂贵的衣服，一天要换好几套衣服。他最信任的追随者也得到了用昂贵的高品质……制作的特殊服装。
red wool and sewn with elaborate trimmings. They lived better than anybody else on the island, eating cask meat from the ship's rations rather than surviving on birds and sea lions like everyone else. They slept in spacious tents and drank wine instead of rainwater. Mutineers who achieved the highest status were those who could overpower and slaughter other men, while those who killed women and children had a lower ranking. Some mutineers sought a high ranking as a matter of survival and to gain access to rations. Others were particularly bloodthirsty individuals who enjoyed being able to kill and abuse others
红羊毛并缝有精美的饰边。他们比岛上的任何人都生活得更好，吃的是船上定量配給的桶装肉，而不是像其他人那样靠鸟类和海狮生存。他们住在宽敞的帐篷里，喝的是葡萄酒而不是雨水。获得最高地位的叛变者是那些能够制服并屠杀其他男人的人，而那些杀死妇女和儿童的人地位较低。一些叛变者寻求高地位是为了生存和获得口粮。其他人则是特别嗜血的人，喜欢能够杀害和虐待他人……
without consequence. Geisbert Bastienz, his wife Maria, and their seven children had managed to survive life on Batavia's graveyard so far, due in part to Geisbert's status as a man of the church. Geisbert was a minister in the Dutch Reformed Church, known as a predican. Shortly after the shipwreck, Geisbert's 21-year-old daughter, Judik, caught the attention of one of Cornelius' most violent and cruel henchmen, Cornrat van Heisen. She proposed to her on the condition that they consummate their marriage on the island, despite being unable to legally marry until they returned home.
而不用承担后果。盖斯伯特·巴斯蒂安兹（Geisbert Bastienz）、他的妻子玛丽亚和他们的七个孩子到目前为止设法在巴达维亚墓地的生活中生存下来，部分原因归功于盖斯伯特作为神职人员的身份。盖斯伯特是荷兰归正会（Dutch Reformed Church）的一名牧师，被称为“普雷迪坎”（predican）。船难发生后不久，盖斯伯特21岁的女儿尤迪克（Judik）引起了科尼利乌斯最暴力、最残酷的心腹之一康拉特·范·海森（Cornrat van Heisen）的注意。他向她求婚，条件是他们必须在岛上圆房，尽管在回家之前无法合法结婚。
Judik discussed the issue with her father, and though both were distressed by the offer, they believed her acceptance was the only way to ensure her safety. So Judik reluctantly agreed to become van Heisen's wife. On July 21, Judik and her father were invited to dine with van Heisen and Cornelius. While they ate, David Zavank and eight other mutineers approached the tent where the rest of Geisbert's family were staying. Zavank called out for the family's maid, and when she approached, he stabbed her. He and the others then entered the tent, claiming they were carrying out a search following
尤迪克和她的父亲讨论了这个问题，尽管两人都对这个提议感到痛苦，但他们认为她的接受是确保她安全的唯一方法。于是尤迪克勉强同意成为范·海森的妻子。7月21日，尤迪克和她的父亲应邀与范·海森和科尼利乌斯共进晚餐。他们吃饭时，大卫·扎温克和另外八名叛变者走近盖斯伯特其他家人居住的帐篷。扎温克大声呼叫家里的女佣，当她走近时，他刺伤了她。他和其他人随后进入帐篷，声称他们在进行搜查……
reports that the family had stolen supplies. After ransacking the tent, they extinguished a hanging lantern and attacked the entire family using a hatchet and an axe. Maria and six of her children, whose ages ranged from 8 to 23, were killed. Their bodies were dumped in a mass grave that had been dug earlier that evening. The mutineers continued their rampage throughout the night, killing the VOC's bookkeeper, and the mother of the baby Cornelius had poisoned. Their bodies were then deposited in the same mass grave that held Geisbert Bastien's family.
报告称该家族窃取了物资。洗劫了帐篷后，他们熄灭了一盏挂着的提灯，并用短柄斧和斧头袭击了全家人。玛丽亚和她的六个孩子被杀，他们的年龄从8岁到23岁不等。他们的尸体被扔进当天早些时候挖好的万人坑里。叛变者整个晚上都在横行霸道，杀死了VOC的簿记员和被科尼利乌斯毒害的女婴的母亲。然后，他们的尸体被存放在关押盖斯伯特·巴斯蒂安兹一家的同一个万人坑中。
While the massacre was underway, Ari's Yance, a military barber and surgeon who resided on Batavia's graveyard, was set upon by two mutineers armed with swords. Fortunately, their weapons were blunt, allowing Ari's to escape with only minor wounds. He dove into the ocean and hid in the dark shallows as the mutineers searched for him. When they failed to spot Ari's, the assailants withdrew back to camp, presuming their victim had succumbed to his injuries. After they left, Ari snuck over to the side of the island where the mutineers kept their boats.
大屠杀正在进行时，住在巴达维亚墓地的军队理发师兼外科医生阿里·扬斯（Ari's Yance）遭到两名手持宝剑的叛变者的袭击。幸运的是，他们的武器是钝的，使得阿里只受了轻伤就逃脱了。当叛变者搜寻他时，他跳入海洋并躲在黑暗的浅滩里。当他们没有发现阿里时，袭击者撤回了营地，以为他们的受害者已经因伤身亡。他们离开后，阿里偷偷溜到了叛变者存放船只的岛屿那一侧。
He boarded one and set sail for the Highland. When Ari's reached the Highland, he told Private Webby Hayes and the other soldiers settled there what had been taking place at Batavia's graveyard. The island's inhabitants were aware of the atrocities Cornelius and his mutineers had been committing, as many were refugees that had successfully escaped the bloodshed. Since Cornelius came into power, the population of the Highland had more than doubled to 45 men and one boy. In case Cornelius stormed their island, Private Hayes and his men crafted wooden pikes with
他登上一艘船，起航前往高地。当阿里到达高地时，他把巴达维亚墓地正在发生的事情告诉了驻扎在那里的列兵韦比·海耶斯（Webby Hayes）和其他士兵。岛上的居民意识到科尼利乌斯和他的叛变者一直在犯下的暴行，因为许多人是成功逃脱流血事件的难民。自从科尼利乌斯掌权以来，高地的人口增加了一倍多，达到45名男子和一个男孩。万一科尼利乌斯突袭他们的岛屿，海耶斯列兵和他的手下制作了带有……的木质长矛。
nails hammered into the ants, collected lumps of coral to throw it intruders, and made their own morning stars from wreckage that had washed up. Hayes had the advantage of being a skilled leader with strong soldiers and a sound understanding of battle tactics. The only way to access their island was from the neighbouring island's sandbank at Low Tide, ensuring the mutineers wouldn't be able to launch a surprise attack. Hayes constructed a two-room fort from limestone and coral slabs that overlooked the sandbank, allowing his men to keep a watch for invaders and take shelter from any potential threat.
锤入蚂蚁的钉子，收集珊瑚块扔给入侵者，并用冲刷上岸的残骸制作了自己的晨星锤。海耶斯拥有作为一名熟练领袖的优势，拥有强大的士兵和对战斗战术的健全理解。进入他们岛屿的唯一途径是在退潮时从邻近岛屿的沙洲进入，这确保了叛变者无法发起偷袭。海耶斯用石灰石和珊瑚板建造了一个两室堡垒，俯瞰着沙洲，使他的手下能够监视入侵者并躲避任何潜在的威胁。
Two days after the July 21 massacre, Cornelius made a move against those on the Highland. In a seemingly friendly letter addressed to Private Hayes' small militia, Cornelius referred to those who had fled to the Highland as evil doers who were banished from Batavia's graveyard. He claimed they had left without permission and ordered they be returned to him, along with the boat that Ari's yants had stolen. Hayes didn't believe Cornelius' claims and instead imprisoned the mutineer who delivered the letter.
7月21日大屠杀两天后，科尼利乌斯对高地的人采取了行动。在一封写给海耶斯列兵小型民兵的看似友好的信中，科尼利乌斯将逃往高地的人称为被驱逐出巴达维亚墓地的作恶者。他声称他们在没有许可的情况下离开，并命令将他们以及阿里·扬斯偷走的船一起归还给他。海耶斯不相信科尼利乌斯的说法，而是关押了送信的叛变者。
After several days passed with no reply or sign of his messenger, Cornelius launched an attack. He sent his two chief executioners, David Zavunk and Cornrat Van Hyssen, to the island, with 20 other mutineers. Yet, they were forced to retreat as their adversaries had observed them approach and took up arms. On August 5, Zavunk and Van Hyssen attempted another incursion, this time with all the mutineers.
在没有收到回信或信使迹象的几天后，科尼利乌斯发起了攻击。他派他的两名首席刽子手大卫·扎温克和康拉特·范·海森以及其他20名叛变者前往该岛。然而，他们被迫撤退，因为他们的对手已经观察到他们接近并拿起武器。8月5日，扎温克和范·海森再次试图入侵，这次带上了所有的叛变者。
As they waded through the shallows towards the island, they were once again met by the well-prepared soldiers and were forced to turn back. Meanwhile, the inhabitants of Batavia's graveyard continued to suffer. By August, only seven women remained alive and all were forced into sexual slavery. Cornelius became fixated on Lucretia yarns, who had already endured a demeaning assault at the hands of the mutineers while on the Batavia. He attempted to seduce her by writing her poems and giving her wine, but she rejected his advances.
当他们蹚过浅滩向小岛进发时，他们再次遇到了准备充分的士兵，并被迫折返。与此同时，巴达维亚墓地的居民继续遭受苦难。到了8月，只剩下七名女性活着，全部被迫沦为性奴隶。科尼利乌斯迷上了卢克雷蒂亚·扬斯（Lucretia Yarns），她在巴达维亚号上时就已经忍受了叛变者侮辱性的袭击。他通过给她写诗和送酒来试图勾引她，但她拒绝了他的追求。
After two weeks, Cornelius lost his temper and complained to David Zavunk about the matter. Zavunk then threatened Lucretia with death if she didn't comply with Cornelius' wishes, so she submitted to his will. That same month, a boy was blindfolded under the guise of a joke, only to be decapitated. Hans Hardens, who had already endured the murder of his six-year-old daughter, Hylatrine, also lost his wife when she was strangled with her own hair ribbon. The man who led the survivor's prior to Cornelius' arrival was stabbed with a pike
两周后，科尼利乌斯发脾气，并向大卫·扎温克抱怨此事。扎温克随后威胁卢克雷蒂亚，如果不顺从科尼利乌斯的意愿就杀死她，于是她屈服于他的意志。同月，一个男孩在玩笑的幌子下被蒙上双眼，随后被斩首。汉斯·哈登斯（Hans Hardens）已经忍受了他六岁女儿海拉特林（Hylatrine）被谋杀的痛苦，他的妻子也因被自己的头发丝带勒死而丧生。在科尼利乌斯到来之前领导幸存者的那个人被长矛刺死……
and sword, then hidden ahead with a morning star. The mutineers openly discussed whom they would like to murder next, and people were not permitted to mourn for their loved ones. Following the massacre of Geisbert Bastien's family, mutineers discovered him crying and stated, Be silent, or you go the same way. Geisbert's life was regularly threatened, but Cornelius believed he might prove a useful bargaining chip in the battle against the Highland, so he was kept alive.
和剑，然后用晨星锤藏在前面。叛变者公开讨论他们接下来想谋杀谁，人们不准为他们的亲人哀悼。在盖斯伯特·巴斯蒂安兹一家被屠杀后，叛变者发现他在哭泣并说：“闭嘴，否则你也会落得同样的下场。”盖斯伯特的生命经常受到威胁，但科尼利乌斯相信他在与高地的战斗中可能会被证明是一个有用的谈判筹码，所以他被留了下来。
By late August, winter was drawing to an end, and it was raining less, resulting in depleting water supplies. Cornelius attempted yet another charge on the Highland, this time with a more deceptive approach. On September 1, he sent Geisbert Bastien's to negotiate a peace treaty with Private Hayes, who agreed to receive the mutineers the following day. On September 2, the entire population of Batavia's graveyard, now reduced to 32 men and six women, travelled to the Highland with Cornelius.
到了8月下旬，冬天即将结束，雨水减少，导致水资源供应耗尽。科尼利乌斯对高地进行了又一次进攻，这次采用了更具欺骗性的方法。9月1日，他派遣盖斯伯特·巴斯蒂安兹去与海耶斯列兵协商和平条约，后者同意第二天接待叛变者。9月2日，巴达维亚墓地的全体人口（此时已减少到32名男子和6名妇女）与科尼利乌斯一起前往高地。
They watched from the sandbank between islands as Cornelius and five of his most loyal followers continued onwards. They gifted their adversaries new clothes and red wine, which were well received. As Cornelius and Hayes engaged in peace talks, the mutineers offered the soldiers from the Highland jewels and money to switch sides. In response, the soldiers launched a surprise attack, arresting Cornelius and four of his men, including David Zavunk and Cornrat Van Heisen. One mutineer named Vowter Loos managed to escape and reach a small boat.
他们从岛屿之间的沙洲上看着科尼利乌斯和他的五个最忠实的追随者继续前进。他们向对手赠送了新衣服和红酒，受到了热烈的欢迎。当科尼利乌斯和海耶斯进行和平谈判时，叛变者向高地的士兵提供珠宝和金钱以转换阵营。作为回应，士兵们发起了突袭，逮捕了科尼利乌斯和他的四名手下，包括大卫·扎温克和康拉特·范·海森。一个名叫沃特·洛斯（Vowter Loos）的叛变者设法逃脱并到达了一艘小船。
The mutineers waiting on the sandbank made a beeline for the soldiers, though they had to run almost half a kilometre to reach them. They vastly outnumbered the soldiers, so Private Webby Hayes ordered the immediate execution of Cornelius' captured followers to scare the rest of the mutineers away. Both David Zavunk and Cornrat Van Heisen were among those killed. The brutal display caused the approaching mutineers to retreat back to Batavia's graveyard, taking the innocent survivors with them. Veronimus Cornelius, now a prisoner of the Highland, was placed in a limestone pit that
在沙洲上等待的叛变者径直冲向士兵，尽管他们不得不跑将近半公里才能到达他们身边。他们的数量远远超过士兵，因此列兵韦比·海耶斯下令立即处决科尼利乌斯被俘的追随者，以吓退其余的叛变者。大卫·扎温克和康拉特·范·海森都在被杀之列。这种残酷的展示导致逼近的叛变者撤回巴达维亚墓地，带走了无辜的幸存者。现在成为高地囚犯的维罗尼穆斯·科尼利乌斯被关进了一个石灰石坑里……
functioned as a cell. He spent his days plucking feathers from birds that the soldiers had hunted. Over on Batavia's graveyard, a new ruler was elected from the mutineer's ranks, 24-year-old Vowter Loos. Under his authority, the murders ceased and women were no longer abused. But Cornelius now gone, a number of men abandoned the cause, leaving fewer than 20 loyalists. Two weeks later, supplies on Batavia's graveyard were running low. In a desperate bid to gain access to their water and food, Loos declared war on the Highlands.
充当牢房。他整天拔着士兵们猎杀的鸟类的羽毛。在巴达维亚墓地，从叛变者的行列中选出了一位新统治者，24岁的沃特·洛斯。在他的权威下，谋杀停止了，妇女不再被虐待。但科尼利乌斯现在走了，许多人放弃了这个事业，只剩下不到20名忠诚者。两周后，巴达维亚墓地的物资快要用完了。为了绝望地获得水和食物，洛斯向高地宣战。
The battle commenced at 9am on September 17. Though the remaining mutineers were now vastly outnumbered and didn't have the military experience of their opponents, they did have two muskets, each capable of firing one round per minute. Private Webby Hayes and his men took cover behind rocks and in their fort, but the mutineers still managed to wound four soldiers, one of whom later died from his injuries. The confrontation continued for several hours, until suddenly, in the early afternoon, a ship appeared on the horizon. Commander Francisco Pelsart and his group of 48 survivors had sailed for almost a month
战斗于9月17日上午9点开始。尽管剩下的叛变者现在人数远远落后，并且没有对手的军事经验，但他们确实有两支滑膛枪，每支每分钟可以发射一发子弹。列兵韦比·海耶斯和他的手下躲在岩石后和堡垒里，但叛变者仍然设法打伤了四名士兵，其中一人后来因伤势过重死亡。对峙持续了几个小时，直到突然间，在下午早些时候，一艘船出现在地平线上。指挥官弗朗西斯科·佩尔萨特（Francisco Pelsart）和他的48名幸存者小组航行了近一个月……
in an effort to reach the Batavia settlement in Indonesia for help. They suffered no losses over the course of their journey and successfully reached the Dutch settlement on July 7, 1629. Two days later, Pelsart was summoned to appear before the VOC's council to account for the loss of the company's new flagship vessel and its precious cargo. Pelsart described the manner in which the Batavia had crashed into the reef, explaining that the majority of people on board had survived and they had managed to recover its most valuable items.
为了到达印度尼西亚的巴达维亚定居点寻求帮助。他们在整个航行过程中没有人员伤亡，并于1629年7月7日成功抵达荷兰定居点。两天后，佩尔萨特被传唤在VOC委员会面前作证，以解释公司新旗舰船只及其珍贵货物的损失。佩尔萨特描述了巴达维亚号撞上礁石的方式，解释说船上的大多数人都幸存下来，并且他们设法捞回了最宝贵的物品。
Among those who accompanied Pelsart to Batavia was his longtime adversary, Captain Aryan Yacobes. He was held accountable for his actions aboard the Batavia, including orchestrating the attack on Lucretia Yarnes in a failed bid at mutiny. Both Haye and Batavia's Bosun, Yarn Avertz, who Lucretia identified as the ringleader, were arrested. After being tortured, Avertz confessed to his part in the mutiny and the assault of Lucretia and was executed by hanging.
陪同佩尔萨特前往巴达维亚的人中有他的老对手阿里安·雅各布斯船长（Captain Aryan Yacobes）。他对自己在巴达维亚号上的行为负责，包括在未遂的叛变中策划了对卢克雷蒂亚·扬斯的袭击。海耶和巴达维亚号的水手长扬·阿韦茨（Yarn Avertz）都被捕了，卢克雷蒂亚认出他是首领。经过酷刑折磨后，阿韦茨承认了他参与叛变和袭击卢克雷蒂亚，并被绞死。
Captain Yacobes was ordered to stand trial for the faulty navigation that led to the Batavia becoming shipwrecked and his role in, quote, a gross evil and public assault. Captain Pelsart was granted another VOC ship named the Sardam to rescue the survivors he'd left behind and to recover as much cargo as possible. He departed Batavia on July 15 with a small crew and began sailing back towards the Abrolos Islands. By August 10, they were less than 80km from the shipwrecked site, but a navigation miscalculation as well as poor weather made it difficult to find the islands.
雅各布斯船长被命令因导致巴达维亚号失事的错误导航以及他在“重大罪行和公开袭击”中所扮演的角色而接受审判。佩尔萨特船长获准使用另一艘名为萨达姆号（Sardam）的VOC船只，去营救他留下的幸存者并尽可能多地捞回货物。他于7月15日带着一小队船员从巴达维亚出发，开始向阿布罗洛斯群岛（Abrolos Islands）返航。到8月10日，他们距离船难地点不到80公里，但导航计算错误以及糟糕的天气使得寻找这些岛屿变得困难。
It took more than a month for them to orientate themselves. By September 13, the rescuers finally reached the northern end of the island chain. Three days later, on the evening of September 16, they sighted what remained of the Batavia and steered towards it the next morning. They dropped anchor at approximately midday on September 17, three kilometres from the highland and six and a half kilometres from Batavia's graveyard. As soon as the mutineers caught sight of the rescue ship, they ceased their attack on the highland.
他们花了 一个多月的时间才确定方向。到9月13日，救援人员终于到达了群岛的最北端。三天后的9月16日傍晚，他们看到了巴达维亚号的残骸，并在第二天早上朝它驶去。他们在9月17日大约中午时分抛锚，距离高地三公里，距离巴达维亚墓地六点五公里。叛变者一看到救援船，就停止了对高地的攻击。
A boat was sighted rowing from the ship towards the smaller of the two highland islands, which sat south from where the battle was being waged. A number of the mutineers who were still dedicated to Cornelius's plan of commandeering a rescue vessel immediately set sail for the Sardin. At the same time, private Webby Hayes and three of his men raced to their own makeshift boat, hoping that they would be able to reach the rescuers first. The two groups began frantically rowing, trying to beat one another there. Commander Pelsart, along with several crew members, had loaded one of the Sardin's boats
人们看到一艘船从船上划向两个高地岛屿中较小的一个，该岛位于正在进行的战斗南面。一些仍然致力于科尼利乌斯征用救援船计划的叛变者立即起航前往萨丁号。与此同时，列兵韦比·海耶斯和他的三名手下冲向他们自己拼凑的船，希望他们能首先到达救援人员那里。两组人开始拼命划船，试图抢在对方前面到达。佩尔萨特指挥官和几名船员将萨丁号的一艘船装满了……
with supplies such as bread and water and headed towards the nearest visible land. Just as they reached its shores and disembarked, a boat carrying four men drew close. One of the men leapt out and shouted at them. Welcome, but go back aboard immediately, for there is a party of miscreants on the islands near the wreck who have the intention to seize the yacht. The man was Private Webby Hayes. He quickly informed Pelsart of the events that had taken place over the past few months. Pelsart set back out for the Sardin to warn the remainder of his crew.
带着面包和水等补给品，朝最近可见的陆地驶去。就在他们到达海岸并下船时，一艘载着四个男人的船靠近了。其中一个人跳出来对他们喊道：“欢迎，但请立即返回船上，因为在残骸附近的岛屿上有一群恶棍，他们打算劫持游艇。”这个人就是列兵韦比·海耶斯。他迅速将过去几个月发生的事件告知了佩尔萨特。佩尔萨特再次出发前往萨丁号，以警告其余船员。
As he neared the ship, he saw the mutineers were also rapidly approaching in their boat. When the mutineers boarded the Sardin, they were greeted by guns and pikes. Pelsart had made it aboard just in time to alert the crew of the ambush. The mutineers surrendered and were arrested. During interrogations, they revealed they had killed more than 100 men, women and children under the order of Euronymous Cornelius. Some also admitted to being part of the original mutiny on the Batavia, revealing that Captain Ariane Jacobs had been one of the masterminds behind it.
当他靠近船只时，他看到叛变者也乘船迅速逼近。当叛变者登上萨丁号时，迎接他们的是枪支和长矛。佩尔萨特及时登上了船，向船员们拉响了伏击警报。叛变者投降并被捕。在审讯期间，他们透露他们在尤尼穆斯·科尼利乌斯的命令下杀害了100多名男女老少。一些人还承认自己是巴达维亚号最初叛变的一部分，并透露阿里安·雅各布斯船长是幕后黑手之一。
Cornelius was retrieved from his limestone prison and taken aboard the Sardin. Upon seeing the bound man, Commander Pelsart looked at his former deputy with great sorrow, as he was, quote, such a scoundrel, cause of so many disasters and of the shedding of human blood. Cornelius tried to absolve himself of any guilt by implicating his various followers in the mutiny and murders, but his claims were rejected and he was locked up in a cell. The following morning, Pelsart and several armed soldiers went to Batavia's graveyard to arrest the remaining mutineers and rescue the survivors.
科尼利乌斯从石灰石监狱中被带出，带上了萨达姆号。看到这个被绑着的男人，佩尔萨特指挥官怀着极大的悲痛看着他的前副手，因为他“真是个无赖，是那么多灾难和流血事件的根源”。科尼利乌斯试图通过将其各种追随者牵连到叛变和谋杀中来为自己开脱罪责，但他的说法遭到拒绝，他被关进了牢房。第二天早上，佩尔萨特和几个武装士兵前往巴达维亚墓地逮捕剩余的叛变者并营救幸存者。
They discovered crucial pieces of evidence on the island, including several oaths that Cornelius had made his followers sign. Dutch law at the time dictated that justice needed to be meted out as quickly as possible, so it was decided that the trials of the mutiny's ringleaders would be carried out on the islands where the crimes had taken place. Pelsart and five other high-ranking officials from the Sardin and the Batavia formed a council and began proceedings. While the survivors were housed on the Sardin, the accused mutineers were kept prisoner on
他们在岛上发现了关键的证据，包括科尼利乌斯强迫他的追随者签署的几份誓言。当时的荷兰法律规定，正义需要尽快伸张，因此决定对叛变头目进行审判，地点就在犯罪发生的小岛上。佩尔萨特和来自萨达姆号和巴达维亚号的其他五名高级官员组成了一个委员会，并开始了诉讼程序。幸存者被安置在萨达姆号上，而被告叛变者则被关押在……
Seales Island, far away from everybody else. The defendants had no lawyers, so the trial solely consisted of Pelsart questioning witnesses. Thus only a few of the perpetrators would admit to their crimes. Torture was used to elicit confessions from the others, including Cornelius. Interrogators would strap the individual to a frame, then slowly pour water over their head until it covered their faces and hindered their ability to breathe. They were then forced to drink the water, which led to extreme bloating and fainting if the torture lasted for an extended period.
西尔斯岛，远离所有人。被告没有律师，因此审判完全由佩尔萨特审问证人组成。因此只有少数肇事者会承认他们的罪行。酷刑被用来从其他人（包括科尼利乌斯）那里诱供。审讯人员会将个人绑在架子上，然后慢慢将水倒在他们的头上，直到水盖住他们的脸并妨碍他们的呼吸能力。然后他们被迫喝水，如果酷刑持续时间较长，这会导致极度腹胀和昏迷。
Pelsart's endured several days of these sessions. He had little hope of convincing the council he was innocent, as his former followers were willing to testify against him. Furthermore, the recovered oaths proved his control over the inhabitants of Batavia's graveyard. He eventually acknowledged that he'd ordered the deaths of three dozen people and planned a mutiny on board the Batavia. However, he blamed many of the remaining murders on the mutineers who had died in the
佩尔萨特忍受了几天这样的审讯。他几乎没有希望让委员会相信他是无辜的，因为他的前追随者愿意出庭指证他。此外，找回的誓言证明了他对巴达维亚墓地居民的控制。他最终承认他下令杀害了几十人，并策划了巴达维亚号上的叛变。然而，他将许多其余的谋杀归咎于在……中死去的叛变者。
failed attack on the Highland. After admitting to some of his crimes, Cornelius attempted to delay his sentencing by reneging his confession, quibbling over small details at trial and asking to speak with his wife back in the Dutch Republic. He ultimately signed a confession on September 28 and was sentenced to have both his hands cut off and to be executed by hanging. Upset at the outcome, Cornelius stated, I see well they want my blood into my life, but God will not suffer that I shall die
对高地的失败袭击。在承认了部分罪行后，科尼利乌斯试图通过否认自己的供词、在审判中对小细节进行诡辩以及要求与他在荷兰共和国的妻子交谈来推迟他的宣判。他最终在9月28日签署了一份供词，并被判处砍掉双手并绞死。对结果感到不满，科尼利乌斯说：“我很清楚他们想要我的血和命，但上帝不会容许我死于……
a shameful death. I know for certain and you will all see it, that God will perform unto me this night a miracle so that I shall not be hanged. On September 29, Cornelius attempted to take his own life by drinking poison, but survived and was in so much pain that he begged for an antidote. His execution, along with the executions of seven other mutineers, took place on Seales Island on October 2, 1629. Before Cornelius was led to a set of gallows, Lucretia Yarns confronted him and insisted
一个耻辱的死法。我确信，你们都会看到，上帝今晚会为我显现神迹，使我不会被绞死。”9月29日，科尼利乌斯试图通过喝毒药自杀，但活了下来，痛苦得请求解药。他的处决以及另外七名叛变者的处决于1629年10月2日在西尔斯岛进行。在科尼利乌斯被带到绞刑架前，卢克雷蒂亚·扬斯与他对质，坚持要求他……
he take responsibility for raping her. He replied, It is true, you are not to blame. The other mutineers sentenced to die asked that Cornelius be killed first so that they could watch. Their request was granted. Cornelius refused spiritual absolution and instead held verbal abuse at his former followers. Geisberg Bastiens, who lost his wife and six children in one night under the order of Cornelius,
为强奸她承担责任。他回答说：“这是真的，你没有错。”被判处死刑的其他叛变者要求先杀死科尼利乌斯，以便他们能够观看。他们的请求得到了满足。科尼利乌斯拒绝了精神上的赦免，而是对他的前追随者进行言语辱骂。盖斯伯格·巴斯蒂安兹（Geisberg Bastiens）在科尼利乌斯的命令下一夜之间失去了妻子和六个孩子，……
later wrote about his experiences. He described how Cornelius remained staunchly unrepentant, quote, saying even at the end as he mounted the gallows, revenge, revenge, so that to the end of his life he was an evil man. Over the years, many have speculated as to what motivated Euronymous Cornelius to orchestrate the deaths of so many innocent people. Historian Mike Dash theorized that Cornelius was a psychopath due to his superficial charm, ability to manipulate others, lack of compassion, and impulsivity.
后来写下了他的经历。他描述了科尼利乌斯如何始终坚决不知悔改，“甚至在登上绞刑架时还说：‘复仇，复仇’，以至于他到生命的最后一刻都是一个邪恶的人。”多年来，许多人推测是什么促使尤尼穆斯·科尼利乌斯策划了这么多无辜之人的死亡。历史学家迈克·达什（Mike Dash）推测，科尼利乌斯由于其表面上的魅力、操纵他人的能力、缺乏同情心和冲动，是一个精神病患者。
In his book, Batavia's Graveyard, Mike Dash writes, Though years of casual usage have stripped the word of much of its meaning, true psychopaths are not evil men incapable of self-control. On the contrary, they are always chillingly in command of their emotions. What they actually lack is empathy, the capacity to either understand or care what other people feel. Following Euronymous Cornelius's death, four other mutiners had their right hand severed and were subsequently killed, while the remaining three were merely executed. Their bodies were left out on display to remain hanging from the gallows until they decomposed.
在他的书《巴达维亚墓地》（Batavia's Graveyard）中，迈克·达什写道：“尽管多年的日常使用已经剥夺了这个词的大部分含义，但真正的精神病患者并不是无法自控的邪恶之人。相反，他们总是冷静地控制着自己的情绪。他们真正缺乏的是同情心，即理解或关心别人感受的能力。”尤尼穆斯·科尼利乌斯死后，另外四名叛变者的右手被砍断，随后被杀害，而其余三人则被直接处决。他们的尸体被公然展示在绞刑架上，直到腐烂。
Nine remaining mutiners were to be taken to VOC headquarters in Batavia to be interrogated further. Nineteen men who signed oaths of loyalty to Cornelius were released unless incriminating evidence arose. Most of these individuals likely aligned with Cornelius to protect themselves or others, but a few of Cornelius's legitimate followers managed to remain undetected. Before they embarked on their return journey to Batavia, Commander Pelsart was determined to salvage anything and everything that he could from the shipwreck to please his superiors. Divers recovered ten out of the vessel's twelve chests of money. Of the missing two, one had been trapped beneath the cannon and was inaccessible, while the other was never found.
剩下的九名叛变者将被带往巴达维亚的VOC总部接受进一步审讯。十九名签署了对科尼利乌斯效忠誓言的人被释放，除非出现确凿的证据。这些人大多是为了保护自己或他人而与科尼利乌斯结盟，但科尼利乌斯的一些死忠追随者设法未被察觉。在踏上返回巴达维亚的旅程之前，佩尔萨特指挥官决心从船难中打捞出他能做的一切，以取悦他的上司。潜水员找回了船上十二个钱箱中的十个。在失踪的两个中，一个被压在大炮下方无法触及，而另一个则再也没有找到。
The islands were also searched for anything of value that could be given to the VOC, with Pelsart finding jewels and other goods that Cornelius had hoarded for himself. On October 12th, the Sardams captain was sent out with four other men to fetch a barrel of vinegar that had been sited on a reef. Wild winds and rain ensued the following day. The five men were spotted attempting to navigate through the storm, but never returned. By mid-November 1629, what remained of the Batavia's wreckage on the reef had been driven almost entirely underwater by the waves. Pelsart determined that nothing further could be saved and prepared to leave. Before sailing north, he decided they should first travel to the Australian mainland in a last-ditch effort
人们还在岛上搜寻任何可以送给VOC的有价值的东西，佩尔萨特找到了科尼利乌斯为自己囤积的珠宝和其他货物。10月12日，萨达姆号的船长和另外四名男子被派去取一桶在礁石上被发现的醋。狂风暴雨随之在第二天袭来。这五人被看到试图在风暴中航行，但再也没有回来。到1629年11月中旬，礁石上巴达维亚号的残骸几乎完全被海浪冲入水下。佩尔萨特断定再也无法挽救什么，并准备离开。在向北航行之前，他决定他们应该首先前往澳大利亚大陆，作最后孤注一掷的努力……
to see whether the Sardams' missing captain and sailors had made it to land. He also planned to maroon two of the mutineers there as punishment for their crimes. The stranded mutineers were Los who had led Cornelius' men following his arrest, and a cabin boy named Jan Pelgrim. The decision to abandon them was intended as merciful, as Pelsart did not believe Los was as culpable as Cornelius, while Pelgrim was granted some leniency due to his youth. On November 16th, Los and Pelgrim were left with a boat and instructed to become familiar with the foreign land and its people in the hopes they might be able to find gold, silver or anything of value. If ships passed by their location, the pair were permitted to be
看看萨达姆号失踪的船长和水手是否已经到达陆地。他还计划将两名叛变者放逐在那里作为对他们罪行的惩罚。被遗弃的叛变者是洛斯（Los），他在科尼利乌斯被捕后领导了其手下，以及一个名叫扬·佩尔格林（Jan Pelgrim）的船舱男孩。放弃他们的决定旨在表现出仁慈，因为佩尔萨特认为洛斯不如科尼利乌斯罪大恶极，而佩尔格林则因年轻而得到了一些宽大处理。11月16日，洛斯和佩尔格林被留下了一艘船，并被指示熟悉这片土地及其人民，希望能找到黄金、白银或任何有价值的东西。如果有船只经过他们的位置，这两人将被允许……
rescued so they could report what they discovered. Abandoning the two mutineers on the coast of Western Australia made them the first Europeans to inhabit the country, 159 years before the first British colony was established in Sydney in 1788. It is unknown what happened to them after they were abandoned, as the VOC never made any attempt to rescue them. 200 years later in 1829, the first permanent British settlement was established in Western Australia. Reports were received of light-skinned indigenous people having lived along the coast. Some have speculated whether this meant Los and Pelgrim joined an indigenous tribe and had children with them, but there is no evidence to support this. For those on board the Sardam,
获救，以便他们可以报告他们发现的情况。将这两名叛变者遗弃在西澳大利亚海岸，使他们成为该国的第一批欧洲居民，比1788年在悉尼建立第一个英国殖民地早了159年。目前尚不清楚他们被遗弃后发生了什么，因为VOC从未做出任何营救他们的尝试。200年后的1829年，西澳大利亚建立了第一个永久英国定居点。有报道称沿海地区居住着皮肤白皙的原住民。一些人推测这是否意味着洛斯和佩尔格林加入了一个原住民部落并与他们生了孩子，但没有证据支持这一点。对于萨达姆号上的人来说，……
the journey to Batavia took just under three weeks due to strong winds and the calmer spring weather. They arrived on Wednesday, December 5, 1629. Two months later, on January 31, 1630, crowds gathered to watch the public sentencing and executions of the 12 remaining mutineers. Six were hanged, with one having his right hand severed as well. Three were publicly flogged and then sent into exile. Two of the younger mutineers, aged 15 and 17, were made to draw lots to see which of them would be executed and which would only be flogged, with one being granted mercy due to their young age. A particularly brutal mutineer named Jacob Peters was found to have participated in the
由于强劲的风和较为平静的春季天气，前往巴达维亚的航程只用了不到三周的时间。他们于1629年12月5日星期三抵达。两个月后的1630年1月31日，人群聚集在一起观看对剩下的12名叛变者的公开宣判和处决。六人被绞死，其中一人的右手也被砍断。三人被公开鞭笞然后被流放。两名年轻的叛变者（分别15岁和17岁）被要求抽签，看他们之中谁将被处决，谁只会被鞭笞，其中一人因年轻而获得宽大处理。一个名叫雅各布·彼得斯（Jacob Peters）的格外残忍的叛变者被发现参与了……
original mutiny as well as engineering the slaughter of Gysbert Bastien's family. He was sentenced to the most severe punishment possible, death by being broken on the wheel. It involved an individual being tied to a scaffold while an executioner used an iron bar to crush all of the bones in their arms and legs. They would then be placed on a huge cartwheel, hoisted upright and publicly displayed, with death sometimes taking hours to occur. Batavia's Captain Arienne Jacobs refused to talk. Although he had been implicated in the mutiny on the Batavia, the only evidence was the accusations made by Commander Pelsart and some of those involved. Nevertheless, he remained in prison until June 1631 on unproven charges.
最初的叛变以及策划对吉斯伯特·巴斯蒂安兹一家的屠杀。他被判处最严厉的惩罚——车轮刑。这涉及将个人绑在脚手架上，而刽子手用铁棒粉碎他们手臂和腿上的所有骨头。然后他们将被放在一个巨大的大车轮上，竖立起来并公开展示，死亡有时需要几个小时才能发生。巴达维亚号的阿里安·雅各布斯船长拒绝开口。尽管他牵涉到巴达维亚号的叛变，但唯一的证据是佩尔萨特指挥官和一些涉案人员的指控。尽管如此，他在未经证实的指控下被关押在监狱中直到1631年6月。
After this, there are no further records of Jacobs and it is believed he died in custody. A number of mutineers escaped capture and punishment for their actions. Four sailors who joined Pelsart on the longboat that sailed to Batavia to get help had been part of Jacobs and Cornelius' original mutiny plot, and three had taken part in the assault of Lucretia Yarnes. However, they remained behind rather than participate in the rescue mission. Pelsart learned of their involvement when he interrogated the other mutineers, but by the time the Sardam returned to Batavia, they had disappeared. Of the more than 200 individuals who were marooned on the Abrolis Islands for three months,
此后，再没有关于雅各布斯的记录，据信他在拘留期间死亡。许多叛变者逃脱了对他们行为的抓捕和惩罚。加入了佩尔萨特乘坐前往巴达维亚寻求帮助的小艇的四名水手曾是雅各布斯和科尼利乌斯最初叛变阴谋的一部分，其中三人曾参与袭击卢克雷蒂亚·扬斯。然而，他们留在了后面，没有参与救援任务。佩尔萨特在审讯其他叛变者时了解到了他们的参与，但当萨达姆号返回巴达维亚时，他们已经消失了。在阿布罗利斯群岛被困三个月的200多名个人中，……
only 74 innocent survivors reached their final destination of Batavia, including five women and one child. VOC archives indicate that 115 people were murdered by Cornelius and his followers, a figure that amounts to more than a third of the Batavia's original passengers. Private Webby Hayes emerged as the hero of the tragedy for protecting those who had escaped Cornelius' men by establishing a stronghold on the Highland. He was promoted to the rank of sergeant, his salary was doubled, and he went on to have a successful military career. The men who fought alongside him also received promotions and wage increases.
只有74名无辜的幸存者到达了他们的最终目的地巴达维亚，其中包括五名女性和一个孩子。VOC档案显示，115人被科尼利乌斯和他的手下谋杀，这个数字占巴达维亚号最初乘客的三分之一以上。列兵韦比·海耶斯通过在高地上建立据点来保护那些逃脱科尼利乌斯手下的人，从而成为这场悲剧的英雄。他被晋升为中士，薪水翻倍，并继续拥有成功的军事 carrière。与他并肩作战的士兵也得到了晋升和加薪。
For Lucretia Yarnes, her arrival to the Batavia settlement in Indonesia resulted in further sorrow. The point of her journey was to reunite with her husband following the unexpected deaths of their three children. However, he had been posted to Burma without her knowledge some time earlier and had since died. She opted to remain in Batavia and remarried in October 1630 before returning home to Amsterdam with her second husband in 1635. Shortly after arriving at the Batavia settlement in December 1629, Geisbert Bastianz decided to write to extended family members to relay the murder of his wife and children, as well as his experiences over the past few months. He penned a lengthy letter,
对于卢克雷蒂亚·扬斯来说，她抵达印度尼西亚的巴达维亚定居点带来了更多的悲伤。她此行是为了在他们的三个孩子意外夭折后与丈夫团聚。然而，他早已在不知情的情况下被派往缅甸，并已去世。她选择留在巴达维亚，并于1630年10月再婚，然后于1635年与她的第二任丈夫一起返回阿姆斯特丹的家中。1629年12月抵达巴达维亚定居点后不久，盖斯伯特·巴斯蒂安兹决定给远亲写信，转达他的妻子和孩子被谋杀的消息，以及他过去几个月的经历。他写了一封长信，……
which later became one of the key records of the shipwreck in Damasica. Two years later, he remarried a widow and was sent to the Bander Islands, 2,000 kilometres east of Batavia, to minister to troops stationed there. He later caught dysentery and died in the spring of 1633. His daughter, Judic, had endured not only the loss of her family, but repeated sexual abuse during her time on Batavia's graveyard. To secure her future, she married a man after her rescue, but he died within a few months of their wedding.
这后来成为达马西卡海难的关键记录之一。两年后，他与一位寡妇再婚，并被派往巴达维亚以东2,000公里的班达群岛（Bander Islands），为驻扎在那里的军队传道。他后来患上痢疾，于1633年春天去世。他的女儿尤迪克不仅忍受了失去家人的痛苦，还在巴达维亚墓地期间遭受了多次性虐待。为了保障她的未来，她在获救后嫁给了一个男人，但他在婚礼后几个月内就去世了。
She remarried a year later, but her second husband passed away after four years of marriage. Taking pity on Judic's situation, the VOC awarded her 600 Gilders compensation, almost 10,000 AUD in today's currency. This enabled Judic to return to the Dutch Republic to live in relative comfort. Commander Francisco Pelsaar was posted to Sumatra to be second in command of a military operation. He wrote a detailed journal about the Batavia shipwreck and subsequent events for his superiors. After reading it, the commanders of the VOC became displeased with Pelsaar, believing that if he hadn't left the survivors without a leader on the islands,
一年后她再婚，但她的第二任丈夫在结婚四年后去世了。出于对尤迪克处境的同情，VOC向她颁发了600吉尔德的赔偿金，相当于今天近10,000澳元。这使得尤迪克能够返回荷兰共和国过上相对舒适的生活。弗朗西斯科·佩尔萨尔（Francisco Pelsaar）指挥官被派往苏门答腊担任军事行动的二把手。他为上级写了一份关于巴达维亚海难及随后事件的详细日记。阅读后，VOC的指挥官对佩尔萨尔感到不满，认为如果他没有将幸存者留在岛上而没有领导人，……
the massacre might have never occurred. There were no real consequences for Pelsaar, as he had become gravely ill a month earlier and died in September 1630 at the age of 35. His journal, which provides a comprehensive account of the tragedy, has been translated into English and is stored in the Netherlands State Archives in the city of The Hague. During the period when the VOC was journeying east through the Indian Ocean, a number of Dutch ships were wrecked along the dangerous and volatile West Australian coast. But the events that followed the Batavia colliding with Morning Reef in the Abrolis Islands made it the most notorious. Although the ship's story became infamous in the Dutch Republic in the immediate aftermath,
大屠杀可能永远不会发生。佩尔萨尔没有面临真正的后果，因为他在一个月前就病得很重，并于1630年9月去世，享年35岁。他的日记全面记录了这场悲剧，已被翻译成英文，并存放在海牙市的荷兰国家档案馆中。在VOC向东穿过印度洋期间，许多荷兰船只在危险多变的西澳大利亚海岸沿线失事。但巴达维亚号在阿布罗利斯群岛撞击晨光礁（Morning Reef）后发生的事件使其成为最臭名昭著的。尽管该船的故事在随后的立即后果中在荷兰共和国变得臭名昭著，……
the exact location of the wreck became something of a mystery. In 1840, Captain John Lord Stokes was charting the Abrolis Islands for Britain's Royal Navy when he came across some large beams on an island in the Southern Group. Convinced he had found the side of the wreck, he named the landmass, Pelsaar Island. In the 1950s, the story of the Batavia fascinated Perth-based journalist, novelist and historian Henrietta Drake Brockman. When she learned of the discovery of utensils, a pistol, and two human skeletons on Inlet's 80 kilometres north of Pelsaar Island, she suspected Captain Stokes had mistaken the vessel's final resting place. Furthermore, Henrietta pointed out that Commander Francisco Pelsaar had described
这艘船残骸的确切位置成了一个谜。1840年，英国皇家海军船长约翰·洛德·斯托克斯在绘制阿布罗略斯群岛海图时，在南部群岛的一个岛屿上发现了一些巨大的横梁。他确信自己找到了残骸所在地，于是将这片陆地命名为佩尔萨特岛。20世纪50年代，“巴达维亚”号的故事深深迷住了居住在珀斯的记者、小说家兼历史学家亨丽埃塔·德雷克-布罗克曼。当她得知在佩尔萨特岛以北80公里的海湾发现了餐具、一把手枪和两具人类骨骼时，她怀疑斯托克斯船长弄错了这艘船的最终归宿。此外，亨丽埃塔指出，指挥官弗朗西斯科·佩尔萨特曾在其著作中描述过
wallabies in his writings, and the animals only lived on two islands in the Northern Group. Around the same time, the region became popular with cray fishermen. One day in 1960, a fisherman uncovered a human skeleton as well as a pewter bell from a trumpet that was inscribed with the year 1628, reigniting interest in the hunt for the Batavia. In June 1963, Dave Johnson was setting lobster pots in the area when he sighted something below the water. He returned to the location on several occasions to re-examine the object, and at one stage was digging on an island nearby and uncovered a skeleton. He alerted diver Max Cramer of his finds, as Max was in search of the shipwreck. On June 4, 1963, exactly 334 years after the Batavia
文字中的沙袋鼠，这种动物仅生活在北部群岛的两个岛屿上。大约在同一时期，该地区在龙虾渔民中流行起来。1960年的一天，一名渔民发现了一具人类骨骼以及一个刻有1628年字样的铜制小号铃铛，重新点燃了人们对寻找“巴达维亚”号的热情。1963年6月，戴夫·约翰逊正在该地区放置龙虾笼，突然看到水下有什么东西。他曾多次返回该地点重新检查该物体，并在某个阶段在附近的一个岛屿上挖掘并发现了一具骨骼。他将自己的发现告知了潜水员马克斯·克雷默，因为马克斯一直在寻找这艘沉船。1963年6月4日，也就是“巴达维亚”号沉没整整334年后
ran into Morning Reef, Max became the first person to dive on the long-lost ship, which was located about two miles from where Henrietta Drake Brockman had estimated it would be. The island where Dave Johnson had dug up the skeleton was now named Beacon Island, but centuries before had been dubbed Batavia's Graveyard. The two highland islands had been named East Wallaby and West Wallaby in the intervening years. While the gallows on Seales Island, where the bodies of Euronymous Cornelius and several of his followers were left on display, had long since disintegrated, remnants of private Webby Hazers stone fort remained on West Wallaby Island, making it the oldest European structure on Australian soil.
撞上晨礁后，马克斯成为第一个潜入这艘失踪已久的船只的人，该船位于亨丽埃塔·德雷克-布罗克曼估计位置大约两英里外。戴夫·约翰逊挖掘出骨骼的岛屿现在被称为灯塔岛，但在几个世纪前被称为巴达维亚墓地。在此期间，这两座高地岛屿被命名为东沙袋鼠岛和西沙袋鼠岛。虽然塞利斯岛上的绞刑架早已解体，尤罗尼穆斯·科内利斯及其几名追随者的尸体曾被留在那里的展示台上，但韦比·黑泽尔的私人石制堡垒残余仍然留在西沙袋鼠岛上，使其成为澳大利亚土地上最古老的欧洲建筑。
Over the course of a decade, the Batavia was salvaged. Divers found apothecary jars, cannons, grenades, an anchor, and coins from the chests that were left behind. Between 1972 and 1976, work carried out by the Department of Maritime Archaeology led to parts of the ship's hull being discovered, then carefully recorded and erased. These were treated, restored, and then rebuilt, and are currently on display at the Shipwrecks Museum in the Western Australian city of Freemantle. The Batavia expedition also features various recovered artifacts, as well as a victim's skeleton. A replica of the doomed vessel was constructed in the 1990s, and is currently in Lelystot, a city in the central Netherlands.
在十年的时间里，“巴达维亚”号被成功打捞。潜水员们找到了药剂罐、大炮、手榴弹、一个锚，以及遗留箱子里的硬币。1972年至1976年间，海洋考古部门开展的工作使得该船船体的一部分被发现，随后经过仔细记录和清理。这些文物经过处理、修复和重建，目前正在西澳大利亚州弗里曼特尔市的沉船博物馆展出。“巴达维亚”号探险展还展出了各种出土文物以及一具受害者的骨骼。这艘命运多舛的船只的复制品建于20世纪90年代，目前存放在荷兰中部城市莱利斯塔德。
The longboat that Commander Francisco Pelsart used to reach the Batavia settlement has also been replicated, and set sail on the last Sunday of each month in the coastal city of Geraldton, in Western Australia. Since the mid-1990s, both Dutch and Australian archaeologists have undertaken several excavations on Beacon Island to recover the remains of those massacred there, and have succeeded in finding the skeletons of 16 people. As recently as November 2017, they discovered another mass grave that contained the remains of five individuals. In an interview with Australian television program 60 Minutes, Dutch maritime archaeologist Dr Wendy van Divenvoord explained why she believed finding the victims still remained important
指挥官弗朗西斯科·佩尔萨特用来抵达“巴达维亚”定居点的长船也被复制，并于西澳大利亚州沿海城市杰拉尔顿每个月的最后一个星期日出海。自20世纪90年代中期以来，荷兰和澳大利亚的考古学家对灯塔岛进行了多次发掘，以找回在那里被大屠杀遇难者的遗骸，并成功找到了16人的骨骼。就在2017年11月，他们又发现了一个乱葬岗，里面有五个人的遗骸。在接受澳大利亚电视节目《60分钟》采访时，荷兰海洋考古学家温迪·范·迪文沃德博士解释了她为什么认为寻找受害者在
almost 400 years later. She stated that she carried out the work, quote, as an honor to those people who died there to get their story told. Give them a little bit back for being left behind in this place at the end of the earth. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
近400年后依然重要。她表示，她开展这项工作是“为了向那些在那里死去的人致敬，让他们的故事得以讲述。为那些被遗弃在这个世界尽头的人做一点补偿。”本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。